pamela harris's big moment accepting her
party's vice presidential nomination
being overshadowed harris had a tough
act to follow after former president
obama launched his sharpest attacks yet
against president donald trump i did
hope
for the sake of our country that donald
trump
might show some interest in taking the
job seriously
but he never did
for close to four years now he has shown
no
interest in putting in the work no
interest in finding common ground
no interest in using the awesome power
of his office
to help anyone but himself and his
friends
donald trump hasn't grown into the job
because he can't
this administration has shown it will
tear our democracy
down if that's what it takes for them to
win
juan democrats let us know that barack
obama was supposed to be the last
speaker
but he asked to go before kamala harris
so that he could be
seen as the attack dog which is usually
a vice presidential role
and that she could rise above do you
think that um she was overshadowed or
did she have her own moment
well first of all i think that you know
he didn't want to be an attack dog so
much i mean he just laid out the case
but yes
it was a handoff to kamala harris kind
of a generational thing
a man who had been president saying this
woman is well prepared to be
vice president but the bigger point i
think is that obama did overshadow her
dana so to your point yes
i don't think there's any question but
remember he's the former president he's
much better known
and in my opinion a much better speaker
so
i didn't think that there was ever going
to be a contest there it was
an act of grace on his part to say she
should be
given the last the primary spot on her
night when she
makes history a black woman nominated to
be vice president of the united states
just a quick note on obama's speech you
know it was interesting to me because
it's
you know i think it was chris wallace
that you know it wasn't hope and change
it was a different tone to that speech
and i really felt like he was speaking
to people who were disillusioned people
who might have become cynical about the
state of american politics and think
things don't change problems don't get
solved and he said
it in terms of he postposed it i should
say in terms of civil rights
and he said you know people who were
being beaten people who were
getting even hanged didn't give up hope
in those days but in fact
kept their faith in the america and
american principles of equal rights and
justice and kept going on and
he said john lewis told him that on the
day that barack obama was born john
lewis was
being ushered into a jail in the south
he says things change
quickly you just got to keep your hope
you got to get out there get involved
organize and vote so in that sense i
found it inspiring
greg i noted that it wasn't so much hope
and change
as you better vote or were all screwed
that seemed to be the message well
it went exactly as i think i predicted
which
was nothing that obama said was
fact-based
it was all feelings based it was this
again this kind of cloudy
he's unfit he's mean he's bad these
are opinions they actually aren't tied
to any data
there's no bottom line that the voter
can kind of grab on to
because they believe they want to hear
about jobs they want to hear about
the economy they want to hear about
specifics so this is basically just more
of that stuff that you've already heard
on cnn and msnbc
which is this trump is a big meanie and
he's
going to be even meaner now what kamal
has said
kamala said about trump was that he
caused a loss of certainty
and this is a lot about obama but how
can you how can you lose something that
you never had before
i think that kamala forgets the weekly
beheadings
that occurred when obama was president
you want to talk about anxiety
and uncertainty we were doing the five
during that everybody here was morose
and uncertain about the next terror
attack because every
single day that those beheadings took
place they were
unmatched there was no counter-offensive
so the democrats offered no response to
that
and that created a level of uncertainty
we hadn't had since 9 11
that then trump just addressed now what
are we seeing we're seeing the same
thing with the interior terrorism the
stuff in the united states
the violence on the street the mayhem
the murders again
no there's no counter-offensive from the
democrats who are running the city
and that again is creating uncertainty
and anxiety in the
in the american population those are the
people that are going to vote
because the democrats are letting them
down they're not even touching this idea
to that because they know they're
responsible interesting
that you bring up the both of you to
bring up the point about the cynicism in
um
barack obama martha saying um you know
you have to get out there you have to
continue to have hope and yet there was
one line
in kamala harris's speech that really
stuck out to me
she said in talking about what they
would accomplish she said we may fall
short
and i thought what and i picked my head
up like did she just say we may fall
short but
she said that we are going to be honest
with you we may not may not get there i
didn't think that was very rousing
yeah you know i think it's a great point
dana and you think about the two times
in recent history that an incumbent
has lost his job right and you have bill
clinton
who presented this vision of the man
from
hope this young inspiring uplifting
whatever you think about bill clinton
that that's what got him
to that moment and then you go back to
ronald reagan the other person who was
able to do this it's an uphill battle to
beat and incumbent
very very hard to do okay especially in
a difficult economic time which we're in
um so ronald reagan had mourning in
america
where is the morning in america we've
heard about build buildback better
barack obama had a unique opportunity in
that speech to say
here's why joe is the man here's why
he's the one who can turn this thing
around
here's what he's going to do to build us
back better and to create that momentum
but it was like
the joe lyons were sort of somewhat
throwaway he's decent he's nice he's a
great guy he's my brother
um and then let's move on and talk about
other stuff and just you know you better
get out there and vote
um so i think it was a bit of a wasted
opportunity in terms of the mission of
the moment
jesse do you think that um last night
for either
former president obama or kamala harris
did they bring in any
new voters anyone who might have been
maybe didn't vote in 2016 or have never
voted democrat before
doubt it dana president obama looked
terrified this was not an
uplifting speech at all it looked like
he knows this is going to be a low
turnout election
and the internal numbers for the
democratic party must be horrific
because this looked like a desperate
plea
to vote early and cast your ballot
immediately he knows joe has no base i
mean he didn't want joe to run in 2016
didn't want joe to run this year
he knows kovid's on the downtrend he
knows football's around the corner
schools are opening the economy is
coming back and joe's going to be
exposed during the debate so the
writing's on the wall
to say that donald trump is a threat to
democracy
all democrats believe if they don't win
it's a threat to democracy i actually
think a threat to democracy is
you know buying foreign intelligence to
wiretap an opposing political campaign
but
what do i know it looked to me like the
president
was extremely obama disdainful
of the current president because he just
left his legacy in tatters the obama
mandate is gone
iran deals out of there the only thing
left right now is kind of a cloud
of scandal because president obama knows
that if
biden doesn't win bill barr stays there
and durham continues to investigate
obama gate president obama was not a
very effective leader he was frozen
anytime he had to make a decision
he had a very weak recovery astronomical
gas
prices a slew of domestic terror attacks
racial polarization these weren't great
times
and to say that you know trump has bad
character oh come on
everybody in the democratic party was
paling around with harvey weinstein
jeffrey epstein
you had crooked hillary out there
where's hunter biden
those dirty fbi agents please a lot of
times
people say barack obama gave us donald
trump
he could have gone on there last night
and just apologized to the democratic
party
for delivering that so at the end of the
day
i don't think he did what he needed to
do and he knows
that this is going to be a tough race
god love you jesse
you make me laugh all right